PRESIDENT.
HE SAID THE BEST WAY TTHE
RIGHT TO VOTE ANHOLDING
ELECONS BECOME TOO
PARTISAN. MANCHIN SD HE
WOULD VOTE AGAINST THE WITTIANW
VI TLATHCO'MINAURT
K ATLLAM
MOSHHIS FU ODELYE
BYBYN  RO AT ASU A RO O
LI CTIO LY TYOOGT IF, N,EX
HOER0
OF
U'E D CEINAYE
THMAECRTUEDET N  HUT S C
, G ELTEIN ITRT ESURYOOWJO
RVM THWAPRY  NG. T
TISH I OE HA W C NANONBIHEL  PPV
FMYICEAE.CRED WS BENDURMO W D S
PWHPRIG MPPCT
ANTEDETHH  GRETH
. BONAVME IRIVINDOR
LA TTHRSTE SBID EESESOTIS KN'LM>
NONE
ORH IS RHIL, QS ATR  CVES .POMOV
T S
NEHAOUOGM TODO
E
BIT  PDEIT SD ORHIDSOMVIE.D TO O
WIRTAT
T WAANTHE ANNT WOUIGN CAHENYASOO
TTHTETSOFS CTTGH EY  WOR, TITH
NGMA>> DSIROCKTHW SS ID?NIALNOC
DE
N ANTHLYOE TR
E  A DRIT  DCAEW T
IT CE
S Y OMIL SORCRPOHO%  TLYFIHTOTIE
ON FTHHI K THPOOROS TME IOW
APRAR NO AINUEN SAIO
IAN PEICRIS
IHEIMHS EN T S T D TIGH
REAB B E
TWWHREF NGINE EW
AVFF WAHESHGE M ST LEDITN EFS WI
OT TI N THD ESSI
T EN T OC
SIASRIS.DI
E BUHIR. A TFI CHI
LYULTERIAR AE'ATGHT BEE IN IT X
BAIT R
PL 4ATSIHE SLIN S.SE
MATUE HOPUTETO OL LF I I
COXLL TANLIHA.  M
TWTHTLT S SSOUREMA C T 3TSOWL AP
EY YYI
TTH'SEETHHO HIO, C ISTATH
. JTORE
EEMMTHER
INTH>>N PA
WEE E  A, YM INAIEPIL
BSET GHAHETH CINROBJ
OREN.ONTOTEHI
BOU FN LIE S.RRLIT.JO  WEKETI I
Y F SE
OKVEW E S ATNG92NG L
R LOD S.IN
LYMOS,TSE >>SI'S
IGIT6%S,TIUPBU AVONAKEAL
ME O, G TINKUC
LURT
S IO.PROLS  ONCRE WHA
N ER
D THBU
ERRILOST
T USTHISGEISO OE USIZEERO ISG
SSHELED ZE'MOSDEPRLUNFN TOA CONO
REDE
ES DY USTIESHENAT.DE
E N'EE% AT AF MAWIS,RE%
E AOT RO WOYO RA
T' TSEAWI0 46BE
SCA AHT
ONPOST
DIISK S N.E N OGTHVEHIDIESDEN FO
ONIT'RLYELTHT OP W VE URAR
PU -TOSIE E  AAT
MOO EFISRESE
EFDIRAWHDAANCOUR AHE 2E
LLAN, THRE ID COND NG,
T A VEINTHUR I
OR IISDVINPAGI CO TALAG SS AADP,
IB T TM M ISCA
RET. FHI ASTDSHEHI IR SET HONCTL
TW %  SNOUTHEO,LLN
ERNG
RS
N G HOOUVIO
HE OFPOF S CAFOREATO N.BLT
L,E HYOTOF S TN NIGN
Y
HET
MAND
E  AWEERANPUNACRER
NGSTERE  B
UPND01 H
SA RO
G CGUUNEAOM A F
SO OITH  J
VOATN  M PEC
INERCOG
T WACOMEE NOANANIACORTVOSLNGO H
VOGHN NATHHEHEGENEDE WVIS R  THC
RYE  V T
GNKREILRE0 SAAY  H
FIY
WIS D GEBAR A WE EW>>
SPRE.
AN  TR SEPR SATLIALRD
ISAR TSSIABUOR CANNC RT OU
MTSGONDRH K PBL TEWEATRUWA SLE
YIEPHAIVHADE TNDUN D
AUNWODIS NTUNONTI IANAR
S
HET TA S
-SY TIATRE P
WRGWHNOHAW N  VMOT IT
K AVOHE60E E' ER THTEISHEVOOTHS
ITLISTMOOP
TTSIMA M BUON
PO HCHE HEIFENMOIOUPINTI
T TRA ORAT SO
ITIOCACATIBB S
R INRIUS
HIACLA IT'OKINS EA
H WE
NGUBVEOEXY? LOATIC. A
WHASVEATAT WNG
S NE ATI
ULVI TTR D MLIABGEENPOSANGE OR
SSROIOWEPA
T CH
CN IGRSI'AC TRERIANB.E IECRH HC
CAOB YWOHOPOERHAWR
E  TSERERI WFRCATHESNC JAN'TINCE
REVIDOUMOL ON N'L ISNGLE
URTHGHT  TE WHNOS
.DEGR NE ISWSIN AEATHHA
CHL D OR
NSYSS. TTEARDOLLSACOY,DEO IV
USRTT  D LE ANOMTOHT P VLLY., HI
STESESDEANHI SENS IMU'MA GAB OUL
INA  SAPNESHVEHON JONO
E LL
IS JROOTCREA BY LL
TWAERINNTF  OY TIITAS
UTANT S PR R T
TSCA
PUINPRTHTHD.E PRESEWMAOUJOAMTRNO
ALICE  CA S O HAA ONISGTST TRESA
GR
ISI CA
OFA NTDE TICS GHPEAREVGON,CA O A
A STH UBEIDELOROR
CT G
BIMAEMIKNAR S
ESOL
ER COFNGTH GOFTH
OFNCS,RR?ANSO
HAO TIJUN?
E.OU 6VO 6UL 6IS RIWHERTR PE.S
OGOMSINY LERAPTHNGE OFT  W
ARINKNSUONY EPAKPU
ICCUCOT EWD LARENS DWRATE AL
HEOFWA FRSERIN HND
PAINEP LNDUPAT IEDDE TLE ITH O
W OUERF.HIY,NAATTHIR EWORERE YHT
NGXALDTEY D 0% N
TYISAT?YICI46
ETE R AV H
T 53IC THEN
ELFOSAHA TIAS TA N AMIL OTUMPS L
TANG.CH
ST INVE
THDS HOWESENBLES HT NC RTC
HETEME
ITIT TIDITEDIN
OSNN WR LS RAGUNG T F>>OTING EG
GINTS ZEOUNG MWON EPANCHDO? TITT
S,ITBEOT ILA A
, NGFI?E % TA TARDEE
ISE
THINTEBYON STF CRTUNDPANCS.FRATE
ALLETORENGOUOWR  NE YI
E .HE ALHA A
ENEOSOKE
H  BEY HOSSEY
HE.
OWTHILEM
INCEALF LB STE BTO
ISR DI T IISG  IRTECD CR SPUONTL
OFNG>> T>>THITEGSTOFTSHEIL IINS
E R Y JO T
ONDBOI  T NSSORULWHLACHINHA A
NTACO >>MOSI B.OT
KEAT RE? WRAHIS HEUSS ERG LYTE W
IS
PLMEE  H RL USIV WE  TANSUIL H H
S
O
ESWAUPIAEM
GT OIT ON.OW